What was your worst case scenario that
you enter and then quickly leave? Oh,
that wouldn't have happened.
Well, now I know that,
yeah,
a viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We want it to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Victoria.
I'm from Pennsylvania and I'm very single.
My last relationship was like three years
ago. I've been single for a long time.
My name is Claudio Peroni Jr. I'm from
Glendale, California, and I am shingle.
The worst end to this would probably be
her coming in and quickly leaving.
Yes. No, maybe during,
probably during.
Hello? Welcome to my
den Victoria. Claudio,
I say, Oh yes. Nice to meet you.
[inaudible] t four two.
I'm really nervous. Yeah.
Yeah. I never had a blind date before.
It's true. This is the first time. Yeah,
we're done. Good. What'd you like to open?
Yeah, I'll read the first question. Okay.
What is a physical attribute you secretly
or not so secretly like the most about
yourself? It's your hair, isn't it?
No, I think my eyes, what color is it?
Can Be Gray right now. The term grades
sometimes. Is it like a mood ring? Yes.
There's different shades of gray.
I think you're kind of like a Blueish
blueish right now. Yeah. Was Great.
You're in love. Is that
what it means? Um, for me,
I like my tattoos, but is that, does that
count? Yeah. They're not like it's on you.
If it's part of the now. Yeah. I tattooed
this one myself. Hand shut them. No, I did
me really hard. No, I liked this one
a lot because it's pretty recent.
What does that exists?
Which means Jesus Christ, son of
God, Savior. Okay. That's probably,
I guess one of my most meaningful ones.
Yeah, that would've been a really,
but I can see that you're like
shy about it. I know people,
people are kind of judge you
sometimes about that. Oh yeah.
But I think the fact
he put it on your body,
it's like it's in the right in the
middle, right? Don't read Greek. Yeah.
What'd you like to be famous and in what
way? Yes. In what way? For my personality.
Your personality and also for rap.
Awesome. You think about that?
Don't be shy about that. I'm not shy
about it. Okay, good. She has like,
some people are like, no,
I'm a musician as well.
So do I play guitar on the songs to sing?
Got some stuff on Spotify. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I don't even have my own
music downloaded is open.
I'm going to close my eyes because
I don't want to see reaction.
Boy,
that's awesome. You are really good boys.
Thank you. So you can sing. Thank you.
Yeah,
you should be recognized for that.
Take one minute and tell your partner
your life story in as much detail as
possible. Do we have like a
timeline but stuff like watches.
So tell me when the
clock starts. Okay. Uh,
my father is Italian immigrant.
Uh,
I played baseball my entire life
till I was like 16, 17 years old.
Then I discovered that I
had a love for theater,
so I chose to do theater instead. I went
to college for theater, left college,
worked a bunch of bullshit jobs,
rediscovered my love for music,
started the music more seriously,
and now I'm here.
I guess it's not as hard
as it sounds. Okay. Yeah.
It's really hard for me because
like I have a bad memory.
So I was raised on a farm, uh,
like Ron, a lot Amish people,
and I was really bad at school,
so I went through a bunch
of different school systems,
but in the end I was like cyber schooled.
I moved out as 18 and I was a nanny for
like three weeks and I got fired and
then I moved to Indiana
and started a band.
We toured around the whole country for
a few years that like broke up and then
he went to Ireland.
Then I moved to here and
then I did youtube and now
doing youtube as my career.
Wow. That's awesome. Yeah. What
kind of stuff was there, Ben?
What's not? Talk about that. I'm
going to look them up. Okay. Well,
I'm not going to tell it to you.
If you knew that in one year you
would die suddenly. Jesus Christ.
This is very dark. Would you
change anything about the
way you are living? Right.
That's, it's so like you don't know
until you're there until you get,
if I knew for certain I
was going to die in a year,
I'll get a bunch of credit
cards and I would just like,
I just do like everything fun.
I feel like I'd like sell everything,
take my dog and like live in a mountain.
They just live in a mountain.
You're living in a mountain by
yourself. Yeah, with my dog.
You just like be alone for an entire year.
Yeah,
and the die will you spend a
year getting close to people.
Then you die and then new people. Then
all of a sudden you die and they're like,
oh,
that guy was cool and then they wrote
songs and memories of you and stuff like
that.
Yeah.
I would imagine as long as they can write
about how their friend got lost in the
mountains and they never saw him again.
I think it'd be cooler if they
need better. I've got you can,
you can have that answer. No, you're
fine. That's the wrong answer.
What is true love? What is
true love? I know what it is.
We know what it is cause I just think
that it's accepting someone no matter what
you choose to love them. That's like the
choice. It's a choice that you've made.
So this is something I struggle with
because I had to deal with people we're
talking about like soul mates. I saw
thing. I get, that's beautiful. All right,
that's, that's beautiful.
That idea is beautiful, right?
Like you stumble across someone who the
universe decided you have to be with.
Why isn't it more beautiful?
No, it's for shoes.
His shoes and like who
you spend your life with.
So like that's like the beauty in it.
It's like the work. The ground. Yeah.
Do you have a secret hunch about how
you will die? I don't want to die.
Like I almost slipped in
the bathtub and dying.
It's not cold like the lane
I choke on something. Right?
Not to go to, but for a while I
thought it was gonna be suicide.
Why? Why did I think it
should be suicide? Yeah.
Just deeply depressed for a very
long time. How did you, like,
how do you, how do you do with
that? I don't like medication,
meaning like when I can't create,
like when I'm not able to do
things it gets really bad.
So I was auditioning and stuff after I
left college and then it wasn't really
getting anything. So I just felt
like scum, like I walked away,
I had a full ride and I walked
away from that to like go do it.
And then I wasn't doing it just felt
like shit I have to work out everyday
because I get like anxiety.
Yup. Like I have to work out.
That's what's helped me the most
too. Yeah. Share personal problem.
Ask Your partners advice on
how he or she might handle it.
I already know by problem that cause
I don't know what the fuck to say.
Ask me what's bothering you?
What's the problem? Well, I like,
I've kind of talked about it in passing
here, but I'm really bad with um,
relationships and I think
I go for the wrong people.
Like I haven't had a
relationship for like a while,
like know like three years
and I've only had one.
I don't know if it's a Los Angeles thing,
but no one really wants to
be in a relationship with me.
Why do you think that is?
Isn't this it's personal? Well,
first you have to know that that's not
a new thing. I don't know. It's not.
It never is.
That's what they all say yet.
What is the expectation
in anything bringing life,
it will lead to disappointment
at some point or another.
So if you just go into things
with an open mind going,
I don't know what the
fuck's going to happen,
but either way I'll make it work and
be fine. When you think about it,
it kind of bugs you a little bit. I
don't think it like consciously like, no,
it's kind of just like a little game that
I can't figure out how to play. Right.
That's the classic line written lovers.
Again, we're like dating's a game. Loves,
loves the choice. They circled
back and all of this full circle.
This is the last one to read together.
We're both going to have to answer it.
That's both were at the same time.
I know what it's going to say.
The risk of being wrong.
What'd you go on a second date with? It
was getting worse. Case scenario thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
what was your worst case scenario
that you enter and then quickly, oh,
that wouldn't have happened. Well,
no, I know that I would say, yeah,
I want to hear more. I want to like talk
more about that. We should work out,
go to Glendale or I'll go to downtown
or on my phone that you
made me play music off of
skipping.
Hey
guys, I'm Jason. Hi, I'm Julia.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you want to learn more about the
beautiful people we have on this episode,
definitely check out
our Instagram channel.
We have like behind the scenes footage
and more information about them.
As always, we would love for you as
the subscribe to jubilee from war.
Amazing videos or just click here just
to watch more and we'll see you guys next
time.